[Music]
wake up buddy it is one o'clock
[Music]
maybe i should let him sleep
okay
[Music]
go for a walk
i have an owner and he's superman let me
just iron that out
they should call me iron man
no
my dog's the best but he's not the
greatest with other animals what is new
with you fellow normal dog i bit the
fedex guy the other day who is he
working for general zod the legion of
doom
[Music]
fedex of course the federation of exes
not to be trusted
what is taking my owner so long
well well well
if it isn't the justice league
superman
what's going on
you're super strong i should be a lot
more dead right now right
my best friend is in danger and you have
to help me well we're just a bunch of
shelter pets
but they're stronger than you think the
mighty oil
i didn't see anything show on wheels
where the heck am i indestruct-a-dog
great i'm the only one who didn't get
any superpowers
sorry
you were saying something
how much did you have to drink i had two
toilet bowls and a bidet but day two
just which is crazy i didn't even know
that was a thing but it's like a dog
water fountain
out of the way cat child
hey deploy canine shield what is a
canine
invade
excellent shielding that seemed
incredibly painful
[Music]
anybody want to switch powers
you